bene io sono qua a parlarmi di
adattabilità nello sport
non è semplice parlare dopo gli speaker
che ho avuto precedentemente che sono
stati veramente uno più bravo dell'altro
io non sono un accademico non sono
neanche un pensatore sono più un uomo
d'azione un giocatore quindi cercherò di
affidarmi più all'inventiva anche qua
la prima cosa a cui mi devo adattare a
stare in questo spazio così stretto cosa
che non sarà molto semplice per me ma ci
proverò allora io vi voglio parlare
dell'adattabilità nello sport
descrivendovi tre episodi della mia del
mio percorso
sportivo del mio percorso che ha avuto
nel calcio
agli inizi della mia carriera
1 verso la metà della mia carriera e uno
verso la fine
gli inizi lo faccio con la
consapevolezza che
l'adattabilità o la flessibili
flessibilità la plasticità chiamatela
come volete sia un fattore fondamentale
per per poter raggiungere
avere successo nello sport
lo di cori con la consapevolezza che sia
importante che per molti genitori che
presumo siano qua che hanno dei figli
probabilmente giocano a calcio giocano a
basket o a tennis
sia importante conoscere queste queste
questi aspetti perché spesso e
volentieri si vede un giocatore o un
trombettista un
tennista e si pensa che magari la sua
forza sia nel gesto tecnico che è vero
che è un qualcosa di importante ma ci
sono delle ci sono dei
delle qualità che non sono che sono
forse
nascoste che ti poi ti portano ad avere
quella quella capacità di eseguire quel
gesto tecnico anche in condizioni non
semplici a sport del sotto pressione e
se non hai quelle capacità diventa
veramente difficile e questo è
fondamentale perché un errore che capita
spesso
parlo spesso con dei genitori e con mio
figlio è bravissimo perché calcia le
punizioni come le calcia lituma anzi un
misto tra quello come le chiavi tue come
le calzava maradona è più di tutti
che poi è vero è vero ci sono dei
ragazzi che hanno queste capacità a me
mi è capitato di vedere
ragazzi di ragazzi ma anche non sono
ragazzi anche gente più esperta in
allenamento erano fenomenali erano
veramente bravi a sicuro molto più bravi
di quello di com'ero io però poi si
vedeva che mancava qualcosa
nell'equazione si vedeva che quando
dovevano gestire determinate situazioni
facevano fatica
e secondo me
ripeto questa capacità di essere
di essere pronti ad affrontare il
cambiamento l'affrontare
affrontare le cose che non le diversità
sono quelle che poi ti fanno fanno fare
la differenza è quella che soprattutto
che ti fanno crescere comunque vada per
ordine il primo
momento in cui ho dovuto
usare questa capacità era quando da
passare dal calcio giovanile al calcio
diciamo di adulti ok avevo 16 17 anni
io passai a giocare con gli adulti ma
aveva ancora il fisico
dell'adolescenziale ero formati amici
non credo non ero ancora formato
completamente fisicamente avevo 16 anni
non che dopo le cose siano migliorate
molto è carità
però
16 anni mi trovo a giocare in prima
categoria con la corrasi
tocco la palla sia rubra rino però
arriva quello pubblico e mi fa volare
una volta due volte tre volte in effetti
era facevo fatica perché se è vero che
ne ruba l'anima non riusciva a reggere
il confronto fisico non ero pronto
a quel momento la io potevo avevo delle
avevo una scelta tornavo nella squadra
giovanile
oppure cercavo di sviluppare e di capire
le problematiche di trovare delle
situazioni che mi potessero permettere
di essere competitivo con loro e mi
ricordo fine allenamento che mi sedevo
la riflettere oppure andava a casa e
pensavo non uscivo con i miei amici che
andavano a fare il giro in piazza ma me
ne stava a casa meditare su quella che
potevano essere le soluzioni 2 me ne
vennero
una quella che
anzi forse ero 33 contro pisa no scherzo
la prima è che dovevo essere mobile non
dover mai stare fermo perché se mi
fermavo mia mangiavano quindi doveva
essere mobile
l'altra cosa che dovevo essere
dovevo giocare d'anticipo
dovesse davanti quindi io mi faccio un
esempio uso di termini calcistici io non
stoppa ormai la palla e la palla ma il
re stava mai ferma la io sapevo che se
io fermavo la palla e è la palla stava
difensore mi veniva li mangiava quindi
io devo fermare la palla ma la doveva
muovere contemporaneamente
è improvvisamente lavorandoci queste
cose mi sia più un mondo diverso
cominciai a essere e produttivo essere
cominciavano a cominciare si comincia a
vedere la differenza tra me e qualche
altro ragazzo cioè io stavo lavorando in
avanti mi ero dato una strategia
mentalmente cominciavo a lavorare su
quelle su quegli aspetti la e questo mi
diede un
veramente un cambio di marcia rispetto
agli altri miei compagni vi assicuro che
in quel periodo 16 anni
io ero bravino ma ce n'erano altre che
erano più bravi di me
però io avevo questo modo di pensare che
mi aiuta molto anche poi nel futuro
della mia carriera che si era quello di
abbracciare le difficoltà abbracciare i
cambiamenti e cercare di crescere con
essi e questa è una cosa fondamentale è
stata fondamentale di tutta la in tutto
il mio percorso dei risultati cominciano
andare bene mi ricordo una partita che
andiamo a giocare a bonorva e dove mi
dissero prima della partita stati
accorto perché loro stopper è uno che
non fa complimenti
andiamo bene
a fine partita andiamo a bere bere al
bar
a un certo punto arriva questo qua
maledetto
fermati che ti do il calcio che ti avrei
dato voluto dare per tutta la partita
non sei stato fermo momento
e in effetti avevo trovato il modo di
essere di essere di essere
competitivo di essere all'altezza della
situazione e quello che dobbiamo cercare
di essere ogni volta no
e questo fu il mio primo il primo
episodio in cui
usa e questa capacità seconda volta fu
quando
metà della mia carriera quando dovetti
andai da dal
dal parma al chelsea
quindi
lascia innanzitutto due difficoltà
la prima di carattere psicologico
seconda di carattere proprio pratico
psicologico perché io lasciamo la siria
che in quegli anni la jana premier
league viola era il campionato più forte
al mondo
tutti i migliori giocatori volevano
venire in italia si parava meglio degli
altri era il calcio più all'avanguardia
supera vi ricordate tutti no il calcio
degli anni 90 fine fine anni 90 2000
quindi
poteva essere anche e soprattutto la
mente al prefetto come un
retromarcia
come si dice andavo in un campionato di
ii livello in iii livello come un passo
indietro
e quindi in primo luogo dovevo
convincere me stesso passo molto
importante nello sport come qualsiasi
cosa devi essere completamente certo che
quello che stai facendo è la scelta
giusta e devi fare di tutto per fare sì
che quella sia in realtà la scelta
giusta quindi quello fu il primo
passaggio fondamentale
quindi mi lascia alle spalle tutto la
serie a
la nazionale
il buon cibo
mi vien da sorridere perché mi ricorda
una delle prime trasferte fu andammo a
giocare a blackburn
non c'è la pasta
anzi c'era la pasta io ho presi una
forchettata venne tutta su
allora rinunciai ho detto vabbè amido al
pollo
era più bianco del marmo di orosei
nella caduta per terra è rimbalzato
aveva detto che quindi ecco mi lasciavo
tutte queste queste cose e della
fondamentale metterle da dietro
dimenticarmi tutto questo e buttarmi a
testa bassa sulla mia nuova avventura e
lo fece fondamentale fu quello che mi
fece fare la differenza perché molti
altri vennero la miei colleghi vennero
la peste stavano a a criticare ma perché
ma perché si mangia male ma perché non
ci si allena come da un'altra parte ma
perché non si fa questo ma perché non si
fa quello
sbagliatissimo è l'ultima cosa che devi
fare giudicare tu devi sempre dare il
meglio di te stesso
e far sì che poi le cose migliorino
l'altro aspetto difficile oggettivamente
il campionato mandava in un campionato
molto fisico
non ho una slide perché vi farei vedere
la prima la prima foto
della mia parte prima partita blackburn
era sul sun uno dei titoli dal sun dove
dicono welcome zola today premier league
c'è la palla
c'è la testa e ci sono i piedi qua
sono letteralmente capovolta e qual è la
realtà il campionato inglese in quel
momento era così era fisico quindi
dovevi adattarti a quello allenamenti
diversi modo di vivere le partite
diverse
in italia in quegli anni la si guardava
al microscopio ogni cosa si preparava
ogni cosa al dettaglio molta tattica
invece lì era proprio intensità ritmo
cuore questo era quello che si
richiedeva che per qualità poi si è
rivelata la cosa più bella e più più più
importante di quella ventura però sarà
inizialmente erano dei delle diversità
che potevano indurre a qualche qualche
problema insomma
però ecco anche in quel momento fu
fondamentale
il modo di pensare
interessare alla loro cultura ma non
solo io e con me ce l'ha di matteo
vialli
eravamo
una squadra con tanti stranieri che era
un problema perché in quegli anni la la
premier league non era così aperta agli
stranieri come ora il chelsea che in
quegli anni la era pieno di stranieri
era fortemente criticato perché si
diceva che era una squadra che non era
non faceva del bene al calcio inglese
perché troppi stranieri non facevano non
facevano bene
per il calcio per i giovani tutto il
contrario in realtà è però noi ci
buttammo non solo io ma tutti i miei
compagni ci buttiamo in questa avventura
con la testa giusta
cominciamo a fare shading con gli altri
cominciamo a far conoscere agli altri le
metodologie sportive dell'italia della
francia il modo di mangiare in francia
il modo di mangiare in italia prima
delle partite cominciamo anche a
soprattutto noi ad arrivare un'ora prima
al campo 2 è andare in palestra a
lavorare
e tutto questo con coni non fu preso una
maniera fantastica dagli inglesi lo
apprezzarono tantissimo perché capitano
in quel momento che noi eravamo là per
dare il meglio di noi stessi per
migliorare quello che hanno ragione e
questo crea una una simbiosi una
sinergia con loro che fu l'arma più
importante
per noi in quegli anni la tant'è vero
che noi arrivammo la vinciamo subito la
effe cup
cosa che il chelsea non di vincere un
trofeo non accadeva da 35 anni se non di
più quindi vi assicuro che al di là
delle nostre capacità come calciatore la
cosa più importante era proprio questa
questa collaborazione
questa questo rispetto reciproco
dell'uno e dell'altro che si era creata
all'interno dello spogliatoio fu
veramente la luna vincente
e quindi ecco questo quello è stato un
momento in cui veramente io sono
cresciuto tantissimo perché ho dovuto
adattarmi a giocare in un calcio diverso
ho dovuto adattarmi a
una fisicità diversa fu fondamentale
perché veramente mi diede una marcia in
più io ho sempre detto che sono
diventato molto più bravo da qui in
quell'anno la io crescevo di età
però
crescere molto in in conoscenze in
conoscenza non solo del calcio inglese
ma anche di me stesso molte molti
aspetti proprio dovuto al fatto che
avevo quella volontà di non soccombere
alle difficoltà ai cambiamenti ma di
abbracciarli e
trattarli come delle opportunità per
crescere e quella fu una cosa veramente
fondamentale
il mio terzo e ultimo episodio per
raccontarvi di quanto sia importante la
flessibilità è l'adattamento nello sport
fuad a 33 anni
quando ha 33 anni voi dovete sapere che
in quegli anni la il calciatore veniva
già considerato vecchio o quasi vecchio
in effetti io a 33 anni comincia ad
avere delle flessioni
dal punto di vista muscolare dal punto
di vista fisico mi facevo spesso male
e quindi mi dovrei mi doveva adattare
a
competere in un campionato che diventava
sempre più forte con capacità fisiche
sempre inferiori
quindi la domanda che in questo in quel
momento mi posi tornando delle domande
importanti come dicevano massimiliano
prima fu quella se io volevo se amavo
così tanto il calcio e volevo andare con
volevo continuare a essere competitiva
ad altri livelli dovevo trovare delle
soluzioni diverse
perché dopo 15 anni di allenamenti di un
certo tipo
il mio corpo aveva bisogno di qualcosa
di diverso ma era chiaro
avevo forza ma non riusciva a sprintare
io ero io ero per massa muscolare per
peso ero sempre stato in ogni squadra
questo è stato uno dei giocatori più
esplosivi non ero alto non lo sono
neanche ora non lo sarò mai purtroppo
però ero molto esclusivo e
non riuscivo a spingere mi faceva male
non riuscivo arrivavano dei ragazzini
che erano considerati lenti erano più
avanti di meno quindi trovare delle
soluzione anche in fretta e questo mi
portò a fare una ricerca quindi
cominciare a conoscere altri modi di
di consapevolezza del corpo non fare
respirare
marco
imparai a rilassarmi imparare a militare
imparai il grazie a un maestro a due
maestri aldo e tonino che mi insegnarono
11 il tg1 ci kong non vi dico le
difficoltà all'inizio faretta e ceci
kong a stare fermo così io che era
sempre a stare in movimento così che
dovevo fare movimenti piano
mi ricorda era una sofferenza però fu
importante
perché acquisire una maggiore
consapevolezza non ha tolti però io vado
avanti
spegnete le luci quando
no e
imparare una diversa una maggiore
consapevolezza del corpo una maggiore
consapevolezza della mente ad avere una
maggiore consapevolezza della mente e
queste furono fondamentali è perché mi
veramente mi diano mi fecero cambiare
lotta io a 33 anni le mie performance
aumentarono non dal punto di vista
fisico però diventa il più efficiente
beh io poi sono arrivato a 39 anni ho
chiuso a 39 anni la carriera al cagliari
dove che mi son tolto veramente una
grande soddisfazione personale
rientrando e dando un contributo anche
al cagliari di allora
mesi smisi a 39 anni ma col contratto in
mano fu una mia scelta volevo scegliere
di chiudere in un certo modo e chiusi
anche con dolore perché tipo un dolore
e quindi ecco voglio dire
per chiudere il cerchio
si è importante saper calciare la palla
è importante sapere suono della tromba
però presumo che che sia ancora più
importante essere pronti a mai
arrendersi di fronte a quelle che sono
le difficoltà del percorso il percorso è
poi quello che ci porta sempre più in
alto ed è fondamentale che che
soprattutto i giovani di ora capiscano
questo perché è che si concentrino e
anche dei genitori
aiutino in più i loro figli in questo in
questo percorso perché fondamentale i
genitori devono al giocano un ruolo
ruolo importantissimo in questo
insegnargli a calciare una punizione e
importante insegnarli a risolvere un
problema
abbattersi di fronte a un problema è
ancora più importante perché lì chi
veramente che poi si fa bingo come
fortunatamente posso dirlo visio di
avere fatto fatto bingo perché ho
cominciato in un piccolo paese
non so se più grande dio e di di
berchidda su questo possiamo discutere
però un piccolo paese molto lontano da
dal dai grandi palcoscenici con un
grande sogno e che è riuscita con l
questa penso che sia una delle più
grosse soddisfazioni della vita che
ognuno di noi possa avere grazie
[Applauso]